this is the place coming up was right
here when she said you're fired I didn't
even know what fired meant how dragons
are really made I have never ever in my
life worked for someone again and never
will
can't believe I'm so emotional
[Music]
you
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
dragons den I'm Diane Buckner besides
being very rich and very ambitious kevin
O'Leary is known as the most fearsome of
all the Dragons but how did he get that
way I really really believe I am the
merchant of truth I am the merchant of
truth and you can't deal with it here in
lecture us about truth when you know
nothing about truth your reputation is
rude and arrogant
you don't listen to any but um into my
kitchen buddy you got to take the heat
you're missing that I'm missing the
mouse to make money the only thing that
matters okay it's the part where I make
money and there is no part where I make
money okay you sucked I gotta tell you
that absolutely sucked period and a
story I couldn't give a damn about
somebody's feelings when I'm talking
about money because money has no
feelings this is all crap it's my in
tears don't mix get over
life's hard money doesn't care your
tears don't add any value but Kevin
O'Leary's own journey began in the
middle class suburbs of Montreal Wow
make that tree was about two feet high
when I lived here it's like 50 years ago
we were not a wealthy family we're
middle class we lived on a street called
Kenaston Avenue in Montreal
I was always taken care of and my mother
always said to me I'm going to make sure
you get an education you'll never want
for an education I got to take a picture
this been so long I got to send a copy
of this to my brother this is amazing we
used to play right on this lawn ride our
bicycles up and down the street although
the street looked huge back then I
remember this being a really large place
you know I must have been a door it was
at that period where my mother got
divorced too my father unfortunately my
father passed away quite soon after that
she remarried an executive in the
International Labour Organization and
his role was to be a management expert
in countries all around the world so we
moved from Cambodia to Ethiopia to
Tunisia to Cyprus to Switzerland besides
a globe-trotting childhood his
stepfather also gave Kevin some strict
advice put down the guitar and pick up a
book Kevin was unpredictable when he was
a teenager and we could not figure out
what he's going to do we spent many
sleepless nights thinking about his
future
I knew every kid in every one of these
houses used to walk these streets at
night in packs looking for a party to go
to
it was great I had my first bread or
beer here 15% alcohol I had my first car
accident just turn the corner from here
wreck my mother's car I'll never forget
that
my hope for Kevin was of course
happiness but we differed on the on the
way which his happiness can be achieved
because he could have been quite happy
playing music and taking pictures and
doing virtually nothing but I would not
have been happy I'll never forget this
place it was very profound what happened
to me here I could buy this place today
and bulldoze it if I want I remember my
very first job it was at a place called
Magoo ice cream parlour in Ottawa Canada
and it was incredibly traumatic for me
and it taught me a lesson I've never
forgotten it ruled my life in business
from that day on this is Magoo's ice
cream parlor this was Magoo's ice cream
parlor it was my second day working
there and the owner had hired me to
scoop ice cream it was right here the
counter was right here and I was
finishing work one day she said to me
get down on your knees and scrape the
gum off the floor and she looked at me
like a witch and I said no and she said
you're fired
get out of my ice cream store right here
happened right here I didn't even know
what fired meant but within minutes I
was on my bicycle on my way home in
utter shame in shock that she had that
kind of control over my life it was
stunning and powerful I have never ever
what still dizzy
I can't believe it changed my life
forever I have never ever in my life
worked for someone again ever
no one has ever had control over me ever
and never will I can't believe I'm so
emotional I haven't thought about these
things in years Kevin always went when
other people were afraid to tread and he
took a decision it doesn't want to work
for anything you want to be his own
master so he started his business from
nothing I mean he had one product he had
two telephones in a one little small
place in Toronto that's the basement
that is the four billion-dollar basement
that is where soft key software products
began that turned in the learning
company and we sold to Mattel right
there read a rabbit and uncle Kevin
together it was just wonderful imagine
that from $10,000 my mother let me in
the basement of my home 3.7 billion
trust me I wouldn't have a cottage if
they hadn't bought my company welcome to
Fantasy Island come on in this is sort
of my home away from home what I like
about this is to be one with nature
look at that let's visit my favorite
room ah my babies whoo
wait a moment of silence yes oh that's
hot look down the lake often glass of
wine and just see what's happening boats
go by sunrises sunsets wonderful once
you become wealthy which I believe
happens when you're not watching you
have to find a business you fall in love
with and while you're doing that
hopefully enjoying yourself because I
don't believe entrepreneurs ever do
things they don't want
you're going to get rich you're just not
going to notice it that's the kind of
problem I want to have with you we want
to be bitching about the money
we're family buddy and I'm giving you an
offer here that is absolutely
spectacular seeing that process actually
occur on Dragon's Den hits a prime
mortal vein in every person the desire
to be successful and to be free of
life's shackles through wealth that's
what's really happening on Dragon's Den
so money does rule my life and I'm okay
with it
I have found my inner peace what do you
want to do with your money
I want more inner peace
[Music]
I can afford to walk out of here if I
want to and never come back and there's
nothing you can do about it that's
freedom that's power that's what I want
[Music]
thank you thank you hear hear well done
alright thank you everyone I was great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you